In 1964, a series of race riots between Chinese
and Malays broke out in Singapore,
leaving dozens dead and hundreds injured.
When it came to racial riots, it was just madness.
I experienced myself firsthand.
And that was when I felt so threatened
and where I was almost killed.
Communal tensions that led to the 1964 race riots
contributed to Singapore’s separation
from Malaysia the next year.
To avoid the mistakes of the past, Singapore’s founding
Prime Minister Lee Kuan Yew and his team aimed to
create a society where different races, religions
and cultures could live peacefully.
Here is how Singapore built a fairly harmonious society.
Singapore has a population of 5.7 million people.
Among the 3.5 million who are citizens,
76% percent are Chinese
and 15% are Malay.
Malays are the native people of the island.
During the British colonialism,
immigrants from China, India
and other parts of the world came to Singapore
as the island was being developed into a trading port.
By the 1870s, Chinese had become
the majority population in Singapore.
In 1959, Singapore obtained
self-governance from the British.
To completely break away from colonial rule,
in 1963, Singapore joined the Federation of Malaya,
part of Malaysia today.
But it was a difficult union plagued with differences
in political approach, economic conditions
and sharp exchanges between leaders from both sides.
The relationship then was just not getting on,
between the majority Singapore Chinese,
75 percent Chinese from Singapore,
in a merger with Malaysia,
which are predominantly Malay,
55, 60 percent Malays.
The community in Singapore, the majority Chinese
had been doing very well economically.
The Malaysians felt that they would be undermined,
should the Chinese in Singapore continued to
gain economic supremacy over the peninsula.
And in Singapore, the idea was that
all races should be treated equally.
But in Malaysia, that was a different outlook
because Malay leaders and Malay politicians felt
they were sons of the soil.
There was a sense that Malays should always
have the political dominant position.
In 1964, increasing racial tensions between Malays
and Chinese led to a series of riots.
Singaporean Malays are predominantly Muslims.
On July 21, a Muslim holiday to celebrate
the Prophet Muhammad’s birthday,
clashes broke out between Malay participants
and Chinese bystanders during a procession.
Violence spread across the island,
ravaging Singapore for weeks,
leaving 23 dead and 454 injured.
In September, another series of riots triggered
by the killing of a Malay rickshaw rider broke out.
Zainul and a few friends were on their way back home
from Friday Prayers when the curfew
was imposed on September 2.
Buses were full, so they jumped on a lorry for a ride.
But the lorry broke down in a Chinese area.
A lot of Chinese youngsters were standing
by the roadside watching.
And suddenly when they saw this group of
about 20 Malays
rising from the lorry to come down
to get alternative transport,
they must have thought that
we were there to attack them.
And the next second,
they came out with bicycle chains,
iron rods, acid bombs
and pandemonium broke loose.
They just randomly were hammering,
killing people on the street.
But fortunately for me,
I was able to grab a moving taxi
and fled to safety.
But that wasn't the end of the story.
When I took the taxi ride and reached the other side
where I live,
which is Geylang area, which is the Malay area.
It was the reverse.
Malays were beating up
innocent Chinese,
trishaw pullers, fruit sellers
who used to be friends at one time.
The September riots resulted in 13 deaths
and left another 106 injured.
About a year later,
Singapore separated from Malaysia
and became an independent state.
Be firm, be calm.
We are going to have a multi-racial nation
in Singapore.
We will set the example.
This is not a Malay nation;
this is not a Chinese nation;
this is not an Indian nation.
Everybody will have his place:
equal;
language, culture, religion.
The Singaporean government enshrined multiracialism
in its constitution and implemented major policies
and initiatives based on these principles,
for education, housing, politics
and community development.
One of the first things that Singapore’s leaders did
was to break down the language barrier
between ethnic groups.
Four official languages English, Chinese,
Malay and Tamil
were established,
but English was designated as a common language.
People in Singapore are required to take English
as a first language
as well as a mother tongue language.
So that enables them to not just
hold on to their heritage, their ethnic culture,
but at the same time be able to interact
with people of a different race.
At first, there was resistance from Chinese parents.
But, enrollments to Chinese schools gradually dwindled
and those to English schools grew.
English is the language of the civil service,
of the government.
Parents saw the writing on the wall.
If English is the language of the civil service,
you go to an English school,
so that your child can get a job in the civil service,
which is an iron rice bowl.
English became in a way
a unifying language for Singapore.
And it was a very important decision
because that makes Singapore so relevant in the world
and gave us our position.
Racial segregation dating back to
the British colonial rule
was thought to be one of the reasons for the race riots.
So in the 1960s and 1970s,
the Singaporean government forcibly
removed people from racial enclaves
and relocated all races to new public housing estates,
where about 80% of Singaporean households live today.
Well over 400,000 people,
a quarter of Singapore’s population
has been rehoused in the last five years,
in these bright, modern, airy flats.
Nowhere in the world, except in Russia...
Despite the government’s early efforts,
by the 1980s, racial enclaves were forming
within the public housing estates.
In 1989, the Ethnic Integration Policy was introduced
to ensure a mix of Chinese, Indians
and Malays in each public housing block.
It's not just having different race groups
on the same corridor and they walk down the corridor
and say hello to each other.
Or they meet in the town square
and they see different race groups.
Their children go to the same neighborhood school.
And that is the value.
But critics see mixing ethnic groups
in public housing as a way of social control.
On a political level, Singapore has policies
to ensure multiracial representation.
In 1988, an amendment to the Parliamentary Elections Act was passed.
This introduced the Group Representation Constituency,
or the GRC which required political parties
to field at least one minority candidate
in each GRC team composed of 3 to 6 members.
Currently, there are 17 GRCs,
which means there are at least 17 minority members
among the total 93 members of the parliament.
Previously you could have a party putting up
a Chinese candidate just hoping to get the majority
Chinese to vote for them
without having to worry about the Malay voters.
But now no party, no candidate
can behave in that way anymore.
But detractors said Group Representation Constituency
was introduced to make it harder
for the opposition to win elections.
In 2016, the Constitution of Singapore was revised
to include 'reserved elections'.
This meant that a presidential election would be
reserved for a particular racial group if no one
from that community had been President
for the past 30 years.
The 2017 election was the first reserved election
and it was reserved for the Malay community.
But compared with the Prime Minister of Singapore,
the President plays a largely ceremonial role
and doesn't hold much power.
The government also initiated ethnicity-based
self-help groups to uplift the socio-economic status
of the poor.
Employees in Singapore are expected to contribute
a small percentage of their monthly income
to one of the four ethnic self-help group funds
according to their ethnicity.
These funds are mainly used to subsidize tuition
and help upgrade skills for lower-income groups.
But ethnicity-based self-help groups
were criticized for emphasizing the issue of race.
In recent years, four different self-help groups
started to run joint programs.
So I wouldn't say that Singapore's
racial relation is perfect,
but definitely we have come a long way
since the 1960s.
For multiculturalism, multiracialism to succeed,
there has to be a visible hand in society.
I think we've done quite well.
We have not had an inter-racial riot since 1969.
Singapore is a stable society
and it is this stability
that has helped us develop economically.
Singapore has strict anti-racism and anti-rioting laws.
The absence of race riots doesn’t mean there are no
racial tensions and racial disparities.
Today, Singapore faces challenges to shrink
the income gap between Malays
and other ethnic groups.
Among the minorities
that feel that they are marginalized,
they couldn't speak all of it
because the whole system is structured
in such a way that it should be legitimate
that the reason why you are where you are
is because you haven't done well.
Whereas if you dive further
and look at some of the structural issues,
you realize that the reason why they are not doing well,
certain racial groups are not doing well,
maybe because there are certain structural issues
and challenges that we have not been able to address
in the last 50 years.
Be there in the education sector,
be there in the housing market,
be there in the employment sector.
All these concerns about income,
the lack of mobility will intersect with racial identity.
And in the long run,
this could generate a perpetual cycle of unhappiness,
of discontent.
Overt racism might have been reduced in Singapore,
but covert discrimination still exists.
Researchers found that over half of Malays and Indians
in Singapore perceived discriminatory treatment at work.
Recently, coronavirus outbreaks in cramped dorms
where many South Asian migrant workers live
has also highlighted the inequalities that still exist
in different parts of Singapore's society.
The maintenance of racial harmony
is a work in progress.
The goalposts change all the time,
and you've got to keep catching up.
But what hasn’t changed is that Racial Harmony Day
is celebrated on July 21st each year in Singapore
to commemorate the 1964 race riots,
and remind Singaporeans that racial harmony
shouldn’t be taken for granted.